Fahrt in Hamburg ist mein Kollege Ralf
Zimmermann von Siefert guten Tag nach
Hamburg
Herr Siefert wir haben ja gerade jetzt
ausführlich die Schilderung von Polizei
und Staatsanwaltschaft gehört gibt es
noch weitere Erkenntnisse über die Tat
und vor allem über den Täter
naja dieser glückliche Umstand dass er
gestern tatsächlich die Polizei und man
muss betonen ohne einen Schuss abzugeben
diesen äh diese diese Amok Tat beenden
konnte einfach durch schiere wenn man
mal ganz da lockt das ausdrücken will
Anwesenheit am Tatort das ist schon ein
glücklicher Zufall bei diesem sehr sehr
schrecklichen Attentat was dort gestern
begangen wurde in bei den Zeugen Jehovas
ähm
es gibt natürlich jetzt jede Menge
Erkenntnisse über den Täter der Täter
ist ein deutscher Staatsangehöriger der
seit knapp 10 Jahren in Hamburg lebt und
der einen Waffenschein hatte und auch
eine Waffe eben besaß und zwar eine
halbautomatische
Pistole die er auch zu Hause aufbewahrt
es gab im Januar nach einem anonymen
Hinweis eine Kontrolle ob er diese Waffe
ordnungsgemäß Lagern würde und bei
dieser Kontrolle ist im Grunde nichts
wirklich beanstandet worden es gab wohl
eine Patrone die irgendwo rumlagt die
hätte er sofort in den Schrank geräumt
und alles in Ordnung gewesen aber es
gibt gab eben keine
psychiatrische Begutachtung oder eine
psychiatrische Überprüfung dieses Mannes
und jetzt liegt natürlich doch nahe dass
man die vielleicht im besten Fall
gemacht hätte aber da ist keine Handhabe
vor allem keine rechtliche Handhabe
dafür gab ist daran gar nicht gedacht
worden also will sagen der Mann ist ein
oder dieser Fall wirft jetzt fragen auf
die sich die Sicherheitsbehörden die
sich aber auch vielleicht die Politik
bezüglich des Waffenrechts in
Deutschland stellen müssen und Hamburgs
Innensenator an die grote der an dieser
Pressekonferenz ja heute auch hier
teilgenommen hat hat auch gesagt ja man
müsste schauen wie man damit umgeht er
plädiert sogar dafür dass man schon beim
Beantragen eines Waffenscheins ein
psychisch eine psychiatrische
Begutachtung über sich ergehen lassen
muss also eine psychiatrische oder eine
psychische Freigabe bekommen muss sie
haben das gerade erwähnt als es gab
einen anonymen Brief an die
Waffenbehörde und damit auch an die
Polizei in diesem Brief wurde der
jetzige täte beschuldigt er sei
psychisch krank und er habe einen
enormen Hass auf die Zeugen Jehovas das
es gab also zumindest Indizien die auf
diese Tat hindeutet
die gab es offensichtlich aber die
Polizei und die Sicherheitsbehörden
haben daraus noch keine klare Motivlage
ableiten können soweit ich das hier
heraushören konnte das wird sich damit
werden sich natürlich jetzt die
Sicherheitsbehörden und sicher auch
Psychiater wahrscheinlich beschäftigen
was kann die Motivlage dieses Mannes
gewesen sein denn so ein Hinweis so ein
anonymer Hinweis der ist eben für die
Sicherheitsbehörden keine
Rechtsgrundlage z.B ein Psychiater
einzuschalten und einfach einen Menschen
der dem das vorgeworfen wird anonym dem
begutachten zu lassen das hat auch der
Innensenator der Hamburger inselnator
betont dass das natürlich nicht geht
dass man einfach anonym Leute
beschuldigt und dann solche das solche
Konsequenzen hat er ist aber vor
anderthalb Jahren bis vor anderthalb
Jahren hat er den Zeugen Jehovas selbst
angehört und es liegt natürlich der
Verdacht aber das ist eine Spekulation
dass dies ein Racheakt war gegen die
Organisation der er
doch wahrscheinlich sehr lange angehört
hat ich kann jetzt gar nicht sagen wie
lange aber dass er sich sozusagen an
seiner ehemaligen
Religionsgemeinschaften wollte
aktuell aus aktuelle Informationen aus
Hamburg durch meinen Kollegen Ralf
Zimmermann von sie hat herzlichen Dank
ja und jetzt begrüße ich Professor
Thomas Schläpfer Psychiater an der
Universitätsklinik in Freiburg herzlich
willkommen zunächst einmal allgemein wie
schätzen sie als Psychiater der viele
Kriminalfälle analysiert hat die
Ereignisse von Hamburg ein
aus ausgesprochen typisch es ist ein
typischer Amoklauf so wie wir tausende
von Malen in der Menschheitsgeschichte
schon geschehen ist es etwas das traurig
macht dass auch mich selber tief
betroffen macht ist eine schreckenstart
und es ist wichtig dass wir uns darüber
unterhalten der wichtigste Punkt dabei
ist mir dass der Täter mit allergröße
Wahrscheinlichkeit kein psychiatrische
Patient sind er ist die Patienten die
wir haben die machen vieles aber die
bringen nicht andere Menschen um
ich dachte gerade mal einhaken es gibt
ja diesen anonym Brief an die
Polizeibehörden von dem wir gerade
gesprochen haben darin steht der Täter
sei psychisch krank aber er weigere sich
in psychiatrische Behandlung zu gehen
das deckt sich ja mit dem was sie gerade
sagen hätte aus ihrer Ansicht
irgendjemand diese Hinweise die ist ja
gab ernster nehmen und handeln müssen
ja nein eigentlich nicht das passiert
immer wenn schreckensdaten passieren
dann fragt man den Psychiater als den
allwissenden Ratgeber was ist der Grund
was ist der Hintergrund wie kann man das
erklären kann man präventiv etwas
untersuchen und die ganz klare Antwort
ist nein wird Psychiater und
psychiaterinnen sind genauso überfordert
wie andere Berufsgruppen das kann man
nicht bei Amok Tätern das sind fast
alles Männer kommt eine aggressive
Persönlichkeit mit einer starken
konflikthemmung zusammen und kann mit
konflikthemmung können sie nicht
diagnostizieren also auch wenn dieser
Mensch wäre untersucht worden wäre mit
größer Wahrscheinlichkeit keine positive
Daten für eine psychiatrische Krankheit
hervorgekommen
jetzt hat diese Tat der stattgefunden in
einem Gebäude der Zeugen Jehovas der
Täter selbst war wohl selber Mitglied
bei den Zeugen Jehovas ohne da
irgendwelche Verdächtigungen irgendeine
Richtung aussprechen zu wollen gibt es
derartige Taten häufiger im Umfeld von
Religionsgemeinschaften mit festen
Regeln mit einer Gemeinschaft von der
man sich vielleicht nicht so ganz
einfach lösen kann
ja da möchte ich auch zur Vorsicht
warnen es ist sehr schwierig Urteile zu
machen über andere wenn man nicht
genügend Informationen hat
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es Beispiele zum
Beispiel an die Heaven's gatessekte wenn
sie an die denken muss ich hunderte von
Menschen auf Befehl eines
charismatischen Sektenführers suizidiert
hatten es gibt die Geschichte des
Sonnentempler in die in der Schweiz auch
mit
Amok ähnlichen Zügen
das kann schon ein Grund sein diese
charismatische
Glaubensrichtung für solche
schreckensdaten
jetzt hat es schon erwähnt dass es sehr
schwer ist den Motiven eines Amokläufers
näher zu treten diese anonyme
Briefschreiber hat von einer enormen Wut
auf die Zeugen Jehovas gesprochen nun
Wut haben viele von uns häufiger im
Leben wie wird bei einem Amoklauf aus
Wut eine so schreckliche Tat
ganz einfache Antwort
absolute Hilflosigkeit immer also die
Idee zum Amok die kommt nicht von heute
auf morgen das ist eine Entwicklung über
Monate wo die eigene Wahrnehmung und die
kann auch falsch sein immer wieder
unterstützt wird und dann die
Hilflosigkeit Unterricht ich kann auch
nichts ausrichten
es die Situation bleibt sich gleich und
dann zuletzt kommt es wie in einer
Explosion zu dieser Kombination zur Idee
zum zum Amoklauf mit dem sehr typischen
Ende des Suizides auch Suizid durch die
Polizei das ist der polizeipräsentieren
und sagen hallo ich bin der Täter hier
bin ich
das ist sehr sehr typisch und das
Hauptwort darüber die Überschrift ist
Verzweiflung absolute Verzweiflung
warum erleben wir denn bei so einer Tat
beides einmal die Aggressionen nach
außen also die Ermordung und Verletzung
von anderen Menschen aber dann auch die
Aggression gegen sich selbst durch den
Selbstmord am Ende
das ist in der Tat eine wirklich sehr
sehr gute Frage aber es passt wunderbar
es geht darum dass eigene Ableben noch
einmal zu übersteigen noch einmal noch
einen hinzuzugeben wenn man schon
sterben muss dann mit einem im wahrsten
Sinne
knall-effekt man will möglichst viele
Menschen mitnehmen denken Sie an den
Flugzeugabsturz der Germanwings das ist
auch ein sehr typischer Fall
hier bin ich hier gehe ich bitte ich
nehme mich war bitte redet den
Fernsehsendungen über mich analysiert
mich und das ist auch etwas das mich so
ein wenig stört dass wir uns jetzt ganz
ganz akribisch mit dem Täter seine
Persönlichkeit seine Lebensgeschichte
auseinandersetzen und viel weniger über
die
Opfer denken nachdenken deren Leben sich
für immer auf eine grausam e Art und
Weise verändert hat und dann machen wir
das am Ende unseres Gesprächs was ist
jetzt wichtig für die Opfer die überlebt
haben wie kann man ihnen helfen und wie
kann man den Angehörigen der Toten
helfen
das ist sehr sehr einfach und dazu
braucht es keinen Psychiater und keinen
Psychologen
das Leben der Opfer wurde mit einem
absolut schrecklichen katastrophalen
Ereignis zusammengeführt das ist nicht
nicht einfach zu verdauen aber diese
Menschen brauchen jetzt so schnell wie
möglich Normalität bei einer Katastrophe
ist es wichtig Decken warmen Tee Suppe
zu verteilen alles so winzige Anteile
von Normalität wo man zeigt die Welt
läuft im großen Ganzen noch normal und
dann ganz sorgfältig zu schauen wie
entwickeln sich diese Menschen wir sind
von Evolution so gebaut dass wir
Schreckens Ereignisse verdauen können
manche von uns können das Schlechte und
die brauchen mehr und längere Hilfe
das war eine Einschätzung von Professor
Schlepper herzlichen Dank
gern geschehen